there's so much to be done if you assume
as I do that the entire spectrum of
transportation road transportation rail
and air shipping is unsustainable then
it means that we've got a huge amount of
work to do to make it sustainable and
design has to play an extremely
important role in that and so that's why
I'm very optimistic that if designers
wanted there's more work than they will
know what to do with to help solve this
problem
probably the most important one is for
designers to be listened to as
contributors to solving bigger problems
than just designing products or services
and the challenges involved with that
means that designers need to understand
a lot more about the larger context of
the world that they're designing in
I think there are a variety of
bottlenecks and of course one has to
consider that pretty well all of our
transportation systems now whether it's
the automobile whether its trains
shipping the truck industry aviation
there are all very mature industry some
of them with well over a hundred years
of continuing continuity so there are
huge vested interests in the way we do
things now so it's very very difficult
to get people to change a habit that
they're used to and they've got business
models and manufacturing systems all set
up so that's one bottle neck and of
course in the political spectrum there
are lots of interests lots of special
interests that are lobbying for
politicians not to change the landscape
too quickly so i don't think that i
don't think the bottlenecks are actually
in technology there we know that there's
quite a lot of interesting technology
rapidly being developed it's more a
question of getting the captains of
industry our political leaders and and
even ourselves as consumers to embrace
change
well designers do have a huge
opportunity to Stewart these changes
through the processes and to do that as
I said earlier the designers need to see
their role as being much larger than
just concentrating on products and
services to design they really need to
look at the complete system of
transportation and they need to
understand the contexts in which these
transportation systems are going to be
operating they have to they have to use
systems thinking as part of their
process they also have to learn or not
learn perhaps but they have to be
prepared i should say to step outside
their comfort zones of the the familiar
design community and actually roll their
sleeves up and start being heard by
people beyond the normal normal audience
designers tend to work within their own
community so there are proposing ideas
too familiar customers or within the in
their design studios now they need to
get out there and actually start talking
to some of the leaders of industry they
need to get to understand a lot more
about what the public really wants and
they need to understand how the
political system works so that they can
make useful contributions to to the
conversations that go on I happen to
think that the automobile with large
qualifications can play a large part in
our future transportation but designers
need to understand that the car is no
longer serving the needs of a large
section of the population it's serving
maybe needs in terms of status and and
desirability as an object but the truth
is in many parts the world particularly
here in Southern California it's not
actually a very effective means of
mobility any longer because we have so
much gridlock designers need to address
that they need to think about in their
own industry there is they work in the
car industry what what can we do how do
we change our thinking to make the
automobile a much more valuable
contribution
contributor to our whole system but also
there are such huge opportunities for
designers in the transportation arena in
the automobile industry or beyond to
work on other forms of transportation as
well you know I've said many times that
the car gets all of the passion if you
like in the design world so much of the
design work that goes into automobile
design is done by people who are really
passionate about cars then when you look
at people who design I shouldn't say the
people who design but when you look at
the how buses or transit trains how
they're designed where's the passion
there and I think there's a clear collar
a correlation between encouraging people
to embrace different kinds of
transportation when they can feel that
there's some excitement in using that
transportation so designers have a lot
of opportunity to say export their
passion from what they do and typically
in the car industry to other forms of
transportation right across the spectrum